bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france selon l' oms l'épidémie a donc à
tort un plateau au brésil qu'est ce que
cela signifie crois pas que ce soit
vraiment le cas où ce qu'il faut
rappeler que c'est grand comme cinq fois
la france donc il ya des endroits où non
seulement il ya un plateau où ça
commence à décroître
il ya beaucoup de régions vers
l'intérieur ça continue à croître donc
jeanne et un plateau qu'en moyenne donc
à mon avis est en fonction d'études
qu'on a fait le virus continue à
s'étendre dans le reste du pays
l'estac que dans les grandes villes pour
l'instant et quand bien même son plateau
finira par être au stade est que cela
signifierait que le virus peut reculer
le seul sans mesures gouvernementales
non là l'expérience qu'on a de tous les
pays du monde y compris le contre
exemple de la suède montrent que ça ne
marche pas ces mesures de confinement
seule qui permette de réduire au brésil
sont pas appliquées soit parce que les
gens sont trop pauvres ne peuvent pas se
permettre de rester confinés soit parce
que les autorités des différents niveaux
de la mairie des mairies des états et
fédéral disent des choses
contradictoires
donc on associe on en remplissant ses
liaisons avec notre invité hervé théry
on vous a retrouvé vous évoquiez
l'attitude des autorités notamment celle
du président jaillir humble sonar eau
qui est lui-même contaminé comment est
ce que vous expliquez que malgré cela
ils refusent de prendre des mesures
drastiques
je vais m'efforcer de rester polis on ne
peut pas le dire des choses désagréables
mais aussi à peu près incompréhensible à
l'obstination dans l'erreur qui est tout
à fait étonnante ils continuent a
affirmé contre toute réalité un peu
suivant son hôtel trump des choses qui
sont inexactes
est ce qu'on pourrait dire que sa
gestion de la crise et est aujourd'hui
devenue politique il s'agit pour lui de
ne pas perdre la face devant ses
adversaires on retrouve pédalant est ce
on le constate au détriment de la santé
des brésiliens oui tout à fait et les
gens qui le souhaitent qu'ils le
soutiennent
ni la réalité pour ne pas reconnaître
qu'ils se sont trompés comme il semble
pas être tenus par le principe de non
contradiction et qui peuvent mentir à
souhait comme trump v10 affirme des
choses fausses alors en amérique latine
on voit la part
de nombreux faux produit miracle à base
de dioxyde de chlore c'est un produit
chimique toxique qui est proche de la
javel un produit mais mise en avant
contrôle de kobe de 19 notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
il a déjà été interdit au mexique et en
bolivie pas encore au brésil
comment expliquer l'engouement pour ces
produits est surtout là encore le manque
de prise de position du gouvernement
brésilien
probablement j'ai pas les détails sur
ces produits là mais probablement parce
que les gens sont prêts à quoi n'importe
quoi pour essayer de s'en sortir et qui
ont beaucoup d'entre eux malheureusement
un niveau d'éducation assez bas ils sont
prêts à croix des choses qu'ils ont
quand on leur propose des choses qui
peuvent résoudre très rapidement un
problème compliqué ils ont tendance à le
croire
chez magna justement des produits
dangereux un mot de l'argentine c'est si
vous voulez bien où on assiste à une
recrudescence de sans abri duo kobe 19
et ce qu'on observe le même phénomène
aussi au brésil
à ma connaissance mais il y en a déjà
tellement que ça doit pas changer grand
chose mais effectivement les gens qui
vivent au jour le jour et dont la
clientèle disparaît doivent est dans des
situations telles qu'ils doivent perdre
le peu de logements qu'ils ont su tout à
fait probable
alors voulez-vous que c'est l'ampleur du
territoire brésilien quel est votre
constat comment faire aujourd'hui pour
que le brésil qui est on le rappelle le
deuxième pays le plus touché au monde
derrière les etats-unis parlent covin
10,9
comment faire pour tenter de mettre un
terme à la propagation de ce virus aussi
peut-être un peu tard mais en tout cas
les études qu'on a fait en sorte
géographe sur la propagation du virus
montrent que ça circule avec les
communications en bateau en amazonie par
la route dans les autres endroits et
donc probablement réduire les
déplacements de ville à ville est en
tout cas des grandes villes vers les
petites pourrait ralentir la propagation
actuelle depuis les gants d'huiles vers
l'intérieur et même à l'intérieur des
landes a observé à l'intérieur des
quartiers des villes en général ça a
commencé dans les quartiers un peu plus
aisés où les gens revenaient d'europe de
vacances et ça s'est répandu dans les
quartiers pauvres
on a l'exemple de fortaleza par exemple
où ce sont les quartiers pauvres qui
reçoit le virus par les transports en
commun les
les domestiques qui reviennent de chez
leurs patrons et malheureusement le
corps vu beaucoup plus dans les
quartiers peau donc restreindre
peut-être un défaut de pouvoir confiner
les gens chez eux ou moins restreindre
les déplacements seraient probablement
une façon de restreindre aussi la
diffusion du virus
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions hervé théry je
rappelle que vous êtes sages et au graff
directeur de recherche au cnrs et à la
sorbonne nouvelle